mon nom et rav4 chad orient bienvenue à
ma première journée au collège maman
alors commencer elle va finir par me
faire arrêter
oui moi je dis pas que cela recommence à
et je te promets que tu ne vieillira pas
non plus tous les collèges sont remplis
des mêmes types d'élèves
il ya ceux avec qui on entend traîner un
pour tous et tous points ouais comme les
trois mousquetaires et il ya ce qu'on
veut éviter je suit un looser a plus
d'achats du coup
mais dans ma nouvelle école excusez moi
je nomme la pire des brutes n'est même
pas mes lèvres absolument tout ce que
vous portez est une insulte à la règle
numéro 22
c'est quoi la règle numéro 22 le code de
conduite lisez 2 que se passe-t-il avec
votre chemise personne ne veut savoir où
pousseront vos premiers poils de tentes
alors oui cette année va être marrante
[Musique]
c'est dingue à dire une prison tu te
vois donc pas ré de pikine iba de bardin
on ne rit pas interdiction d'aller aux
toilettes quoi quoi
s'y trouvaient dans deux mois vite ce
cas je ne ressemble pas à ça la
créativité n'a pas sa place dans cette
école pour nouveau principal et nas
il est temps pour nous de parler pour
ceux qui se taisent nous devons faire
quelque chose à propos de cette école
nous devons nous exprimer librement et
ne pas être qu'une bande de robots ce
principal est affreux on ne roule pas à
vélo sur le campus je vous confie ce que
ceux-ci housse tu veux te démarquer des
autres si tu veux faire la différence
bien sortir du moule très bien les gars
vous connaissez tous votre émission
enfreignons toutes les règles de ce code
conduite ridicule d'accord
khatchadourian je te suis tu viens de
dire mon prénom règles 28 pas de balle
dans les couloirs ça aurait pu être
moins règle 17 pas de coloration
d'aucune sorte et règles 34 quelqu'un de
remettre à jour wikipedia parce qu'on
écrit l'histoire la m on ne touche pas à
la vitrine de trophées et poissons c'est
une basse et pas trop
[Musique]
je trouverais ces hooligans et je les
détruire et pour la justice en règle
absurde formate les élèves qu'est-ce que
tu viennes bien celui qui a fait ça
c'est un artiste ça tombe bien parmi
vous un test qui commence avec le
principal doit est à 3 teto et bien
c'est faux mettez faux je suis venu au
monde sans sur kto pour votre
information et je suis très beau comme
ça
[Musique]